stop thinking and start doing one of my
favorite stories is of Mary Kay Ash she
was a successful entrepreneur founder of
Mary Kay Cosmetics her life changed when
she was a young mother and her husband
came back from the war and ran off with
another woman
and she now had to find a way to support
the family so she joined up with a
direct sales company and was selling
things door-to-door and she quickly
became the number one salesperson at the
business but she was passed over on
opportunities for promotion because she
was a woman she kept seeing men with
less experience less success be promoted
ahead of her so she said I'm tired of
this I'm not going to do this anymore
I'm gonna go find another company so she
hooked up with a different direct sales
company she brought her experience there
and again she quickly became one of the
top salespeople there and sharing a few
promotions and she even got on the board
of directors but she kept getting put
down because she was a woman you know
her ideals would be ignored and the
board would frequently tell her Oh Mary
Kay you're just thinking like a woman a
comment that that constantly infuriated
her she got so frustrated and her
breaking point came when one of the guys
that she trained for years at the
business was promoted to be her boss and
paid twice her salary and she said
that's it I'm done I can't handle these
companies I'm not being respected I'm
not being treated like I'm adding value
so I'm done and she quit and she went
home and said you know what I'm going to
write a book I'm going to write a book
and I talked about all the reasons why
corporate America is wrong right now and
how women are being passed over and how
this isn't right and then I'm also going
to include a section on what an ideal
company should look like how people will
be treated with respect and how business
should be run and then the turning point
came she said instead of just thinking
about it
instead of just writing about it I'm
gonna go do it I'm going to launch my
own business that will be the ideal
company to work for and she turned all
negative things that happened to her in
her life how she was passed over
repeatedly and being put down for being
a woman should all that negative energy
and turned into something amazingly
positive and took an idea from nothing
from scratch just an idea into a billion
dollar plus company and when she was
asked what do you think your legacy is
going to be she said I think the biggest
legacy we're going to leave is a whole
community of children who believe they
can do anything in this world because
they watch their mamas do it so stop
thinking about it stop writing about it
and start doing believe for those you're
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more videos for you let me know what you
think leave a comment underneath
ask me a question I'm a good video
response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel see more videos
like this thank you so much I'll see you
soon